let's talk about the the alien s this is
a book that was I'm gonna say this book
is 25 years 25 years old
Caleb Carr wrote it I remember reading
it when it first came out I think in 93
and it's a fantastic book it's set in
the late 1800s in New York City and it's
a group of people figuring out that
there's something called a serial killer
before that concept even exists right
yes it was still people didn't
well that that name hadn't even been
given to that sort of killer so it's the
beginning of many many things that to
that time in New York City as was a time
of electricity of lighting of the
telephone it was also the time when
forensic science was and it's in its
basic forms you know the thumb prints
and using cameras of photography and so
many wonderful things and they're all
incorporated into this this this very
dark sinister story about a serial
killer who is killing young children in
in New York City in a time when New York
City was not regulated I was run by a
very corrupt police force that was taken
over by Theodore Roosevelt yes before he
became mayor of New York and then laying
on a later on vice president and
president he was yeah he took over to
try and clean up the police force and
he's he's a fantastic character in and
then the two fictional characters that
Daniel Bruhl myself play we are hit
Harvard we went to Harvard with with
Roosevelt and so we especially the
alienist who is played by Daniel Daniel
Bruhl believes that this is a this is a
serial killer who's gonna get away with
more and more murders because the police
force are ignoring the obvious signs and
so Roosevelt allows us to run a parallel
investigation which gets everyone into a
lot of trouble but it has to happen for
us to find the kid is absolutely
stunning the way that you that your crew
your production crew recreated New York
in the 1880s 1890's it's absolutely
stunning
you